Tylar asks when have you been happiest
in life Tyler I took this question for a
very specific reason because I think one
of the interesting things about the
askgaryvee show is this content and
actual infrastructure has forced me to
go deeper than I have in any other
platform and it's been interesting to
watch what a lot of you in the
vaynernation have been responding well
to which is a little bit more insight to
my psychology and I think this question
gave me the opportunity to answer it and
I'm gonna really throw you for an
interesting curveball and this is 100%
the answer I am the happiest in my life
of all time right this second that's
just the truth and what I mean by that
is is this moment what these characters
show them you know you know do they know
d-roc excuse me do they know Alex Diaz
he's been sick for a couple days so he
looks terrible is this moment with these
characters the best moment of course not
last night beating the Cavaliers going
to Cleveland from LeBrons homecoming and
dominating and stunning the world was an
amazing by the way
Cleveland you're gonna hate me for this
I've been getting cleaved a lot of love
I was disappointed with the fans this
was LeBron go son coming home and they
it wasn't enough like a random like
second-round Knicks home game energy in
the garden was better I was very
disappointed I'm not this thing and I
know Cleveland fans are awesome and
they're tough I respect Cleveland it's a
tough town not a lot of championships
for a long time was disappointed I had
to throw that rub in there because
that's how I roll
um children being born Jets beating the
Patriots in New England in the second
round of playoffs after losing 45 to 3
in a Monday night game just a couple
weeks earlier way up there probably my
happiest moment my wife and kids know
but if you ask me happiness I'm a
collector I'm a momentum guy I'm a
hugger and so you know every day that
goes by that good things keep happening
and no death and that's how I look at it
is happening in my family or sickness
or Terminal conclusions to anybody I
care about feels like the next best day
it feels like it's always getting better
I don't know if one day look I'm gonna
be very honest with you guys in my
deepest fear because I'm positive I
don't talk about negativity my deepest
fear is that eventually I become bitter
right that I pushed the long game too
long and I didn't capitalize that I
missed moments but right now I still
think I'm on the client I don't think
I'm on the other side of the hill and so
hopefully I always have that psychology
even to the last breath that I take but
to me the happiest moment is right now
because everything is collectively
always getting better even when it's not
you know there's always gonna be
challenges it still is
I just that's how I see it oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe